the nation is not for sale chanted this
people outside Argentina's
Congress it happened after lawmakers
passed president Javier M's Landmark
Bill meant to begin transforming the
state and the economy critics say the
government will use the bill to increase
the exploitation of Natural Resources
benefit the private sector and cut
resources for the environment and
culture this is what we're seeing a
group of 40 businessmen guide M's
policies and the rights that argentine's
had are at risk the bill touches
fundamental issues that affect people
the working class the debate lasted for
3 days and the government had to give in
to the demands of other political
parties the bill initially had over 600
laws it ended with a little over
300 this bill is a big political test
for Javier M and his H to reform
Argentina it's been St filled with
tensions in and out of Congress while
lawmakers were discussing which reforms
to carry out in order to get the bill
approved thousands of people gathered
outside to express their concerns with
Javier M's plans for
Argentina violent clashes between
protesters and security forces have
taken place throughout the debate the
government says Argentina's economy
needs to be modernized to attract
foreign investment they also blame the
previous administration for soaring
inflation the dire economic situation
and the lack of forign reserves in the
central
bank people say this government doesn't
listen to social need this government is
authoritarian exploitative and
anti-democratic that's the only thing
they can say because the government took
office 50 days and found over 1,000
inflation rate in the past years 1,000
and you're talking about us 50 days
we've been in power but the bill still
needs to be revised law by law and then
ratified in the
Senate mle won with 56% of the votes in
December and says he has the legitimacy
to implement his austerity measures to
reduce government spending and fight
inflation but those against him say his
measures will bring even greater
economic Despair and promise to fight
back Thea Al
buenos make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
ja